now israelis and palestinians are
picking up the pieces after the latest
outbreak of violence shook the region
experts say the damage inflicted by
israeli airstrikes in gaza will likely
take years to repair
and cost millions dw's tanya kramer sent
us this report from gaza city where a
fragile ceasefire has been in place
since friday picking through the rubble
in just 11 days homes shops and roads
have been wiped out
and hundreds of lives have been lost
survivors of the airstrikes on gaza city
are dealing with the aftermath
adelie alcolac has lost over 10 of his
family members
in an airstrike
it's an inexplicable feeling frustration
fears sadness i can't process what
happened
i don't understand i'm in shock in just
a couple of seconds
minutes
residents are returning from wherever
they could find shelter
some feel like nowhere is safe in gaza
three wars each more difficult than the
last
this time around the strikes were
concentrated on recreational buildings
facilities media offices lively areas in
gaza
this will of course have a psychological
effect on us
three wars have affected gaza we try to
rise
bit by bit and they pull us back they
target
everything even after the ceasefire
gaza still faces another dangerous
crisis
the coronavirus pandemic
we had the second wave of coved in gaza
the hospital was ever
overwhelmed you know we have no vaccines
enough vaccines for the population we
don't have
enough testing and then this came this
war
there was a huge destruction of the main
roads
the electricity the water the waste
management
the air strikes have stopped but their
impacts will be felt
for a long time